so it's time to play some more dragons
demon [ __ ] how hard can it be big demon
charge in this episode we go into bligh
town and you brothers have warned me
about blight tiny bro said it cuz Vikon
is a [ __ ] nightmare I have my bath
salts I'm ready to do this
if deaths is bad then I can't even
imagine what blight town is gonna be I
can't have an end to blight on for that
day I'm gonna have to upgrade my Albert
sure I'll give you my large Ember that's
a real kinky [ __ ] that's what I wanted I
want to kill them in one hey if I'm can
it looks like there's something over
here what are you doing here ring of
sacrifice oh I should wear it say that
for a important oh I should have used it
now
Oh alright let's got a black man are we
there yet are we there yet are we there
yet are we there yet oh definitely not
now don't tell me this is the Frog
please let me stay in court oh are we
there yet
hey man you need new wallpapers man it's
better be as bad as everyone says I'm I
bet I'm not even gonna die a single die
not ha ha ha ha ha nearly died the first
[ __ ] second I turn ugly ugly oh no
this is your place oh no I'm so sorry
this thing's almost as ugly as you are
Oh mamacita senorita so far so good and
I got a pie nice these guys sweat a lot
jeez
he's using a body that's the best weapon
I've ever seen holy [ __ ]
what are you doing hey [ __ ] I'm I hate
for these [ __ ]
yeah this is gonna be a problem this is
not a town this is a hellhole to Justin
Bieber's vagina oh he's not dead
oh well he's dead now hahaha that a is
that a is that a I could jump there
directly I wonder if that's a good idea
takes [ __ ] five minutes just to get
back I swear to god they're not too bad
once you get to know him you know just
like my dear dad Dennis my dead friend
Dennis he's great yeah I'm an idiot oh
it's on everyone else putting the
[ __ ] dick cuz of your face makes you
play battery blow blow whoa [ __ ] my ass
out Blighttown more like [ __ ] me in the
ass town I'm gonna try something he fell
down hahahaha alright let's do that on
all of them yes best tactic ever idiot
yeah but I gotta finish the entire
dungeon like this oh [ __ ] these [ __ ]
can climb oh god I fell down oh god what
is he doing that's what you get for me
ugly and purple it's Justin Bieber's
favorite god I love Justin he sings like
an angel I never made it this far
there's like this arrow guy who keeps
shooting me it's you you'll fart oh god
he almost poisoned me this bridge looks
safe oh god it moves hahaha ugly pots
should I make the jump I guess I should
yeah stupid pot stupid hot hot hot oh
you're not a pot is that you oh my
[ __ ] god
what Blighttown ici town as a man in the
pot how are thou man in the pot you are
afraid but I saved you from the pot get
pots are on the right side after all ah
son of a [ __ ]
nice try pits always threw up on me
come on at least ask first God Oh what
the [ __ ] is that not only is the game
hard it's [ __ ] terrifying to look at
what is that you know what let's just
[ __ ] kill him the best way possible I
mean let's be honest some things are
just too ugly to keep alive Oh God Oh
God
sacrifice her don't take man gonna get
map engine hey just don't go too close
[ __ ] me in the [ __ ] ass did you see
that Maya don't fold on your pizza where
am i where am I
hello I love a good vibe black town is
the best town Blyton is the best town
like to understand first town stabbed
[ __ ] [ __ ] samba still to fall down
oh god I'm almost a while you playing
with my feelings like that
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so [ __ ] that thing not literally
for God's sake come on you dick not for
long I get toasted like a [ __ ]
umbrella like it's a wheel minute idiom
oh oh you're gonna die now [ __ ]
I'm stuck I'm huh no no no come on why
I'm so [ __ ] stuck oh he came all over
oh [ __ ] it's the fatties oh [ __ ]
I seriously cry everything hired a [ __ ]
in Maine for one nipple to nipple pick
three nipples I saw a healthy back that
you can burp all you want that's not
gonna make me not like you mean like you
whatever okay if I die because I'm an
idiot I die because I guess I'm an idiot
Ted guy a solution to move that why do I
[ __ ] suck more than a Dunkin [ __ ]
you're for fun man [ __ ] oven Jesus cries
ladies one at a time seriously that ass
this game has great ass I should just
call it demon ass oh oh oh wait that
yeah I mean it's good that I can see
once the action at least Oh
okay where's the fatty fat fat fat [ __ ]
did he fall down
I think if nope he's there he's just
been chilling all night long he has
friends now cool
it's my [ __ ] friend all I got is a
dead guy with a thong that's all I guess
[ __ ] you fat fat fat right right right
right right
what my buddy hey look back there and
you [ __ ] dead you piece of sweaty
[ __ ] I don't know why I had so
much [ __ ] trouble at this party
where's my bone fire gimme me a DJ well
what the hell are you what the [ __ ] are
you die spine of satire oh god what that
[ __ ] is that
oh oh
oh not today not today [ __ ]
not today oh god they're poison
stop Chang darshan I'm so scared of
dying or falling down or anything there
- anything what the [ __ ] the mud is
poisoned bonfire where the [ __ ] are you
stab them in the butt one time and see
if they like it don't do it on girls
though don't do their own girls go am I
ever supposed to be here where am I
mom please this doesn't look nice what
it what it hello a plank shield thanks
man
oh [ __ ] so [ __ ] money huh
take dice just wanna make it so easy man
this place this place is great love this
face on fire oh my love this face leave
it like if you love this place - and it
hits the sky come bro today I see
brothers the next one say awesome Bobby
[Music]